The good estimates are that the Russians
killed about 30 million of their own
people between 19,
19 in 1959,
you know,
and it's,
it's brutal.
It's brutal.
A lot of that was through starvation.
No,
I saw a photograph the other day which I
tweeted,
which is the worst photograph I've ever
seen in my life and that's actually
saying a lot because I've seen a lot of
really terrible photographs because I've
done so much investigation into
totalitarianism and this was a
photograph that was taken during one of
the early starvation periods in,
in the Soviet Union were about $3
billion peasants died.
It was a picture of a peasant couple
standing behind a table at a market
selling human body parts for food.
It's like,
and you know,
I have this weird quirk,
which I don't think does me much good,
but maybe helps me understand things
better when I see that someone has done
something extreme.
I learned to do this a long time ago
when I worked briefly in a maximum
security prison.
I tried to imagine what I would have to
be like,
what kind of situation I would have to
find myself and to do that and believe
me,
man,
that's a horrifying enter.
That's a horrifying enterprise because
it is actually possible.
No matter what it is that you read about
someone doing and no matter how unlikely
it is that you think you would do that,
it's possible to imagine yourself in
that situation
and that.
Well,
that's enlightening.
That's what I would say.
That's enlightening.
You know,
because one of the things about
enlightenment is is that you get
enlightened by doing things that are
necessary that you really,
really,
really do not want to know.
You don't want to do.
And imagining imagining yourself as a
perpetrator of that sort is that tells
you something about the world and that
tells you something about human beings.
But it's a hell of a thing to swallow.
You know,
and in a very well structured society
like ours where were so peaceful.
Well,
because we have the heat and it always
works and we have electricity and it
always works.
And we have plumbing,
which is a bloody miracle,
and it always works,
you know,
it's just one of the things that this
imagination process has done for me is
keep me alert
to the absolute miracle that my life is
every day.
It's horribly cold out there.
You can't grow any food.
You die if you're out there for 24
hours.
If any of this infrastructure was
unreliable for any length of time,
we would be in serious trouble.
And it's never unreliable.
It's so unlikely.
And so here we are with all this
reliable infrastructure and because of
that,
we don't really have to compete with
each other much.
I mean,
some you don't compete for food,
you don't compete for shelter or some
people do,
but not very many.
So it's really easy to think of yourself
as good because you're not doing
anything nasty to anyone.
But you know,
a cynic might say,
well that's just because you don't have
any reason to.
But those reasons have arisen many times
in the past.
And in fact they're the norm,
not the exception.
We're the exception,
this insanely functional society that
we've somehow managed to generate is
it's incomprehensible to me that it
exists.